Professor David Blight:
On the 4^(th) of July,
1854, in an outdoor park in
Framingham,
Massachusetts,
which is fifteen,
twenty miles west of Boston,
William Lloyd Garrison and the
Massachusetts Anti-Slavery
Society built a stage.
They had a huge turnout.
And Garrison and his group
performed an act of abolitionist
theater.
Anthony Burns had just been
returned to slavery in Virginia.
The Kansas-Nebraska Act had
just been passed in the month of
May.
Behind him, on the stage--a
huge array--was first the
insignia of the State of
Virginia,
then an insignia of the State
of Massachusetts,
a banner on one side that read
"Redeem Massachusetts."
Hanging from that sign was
something labeled "the crepe of
servitude"--nothing very subtle
about this.
And two flags were on other
side of the rostrum,
one labeled Kansas and the
other labeled Nebraska,
and behind Garrison was a very
large United States flag,
upside down.
Now, this was political
theater, directed by a man who,
as you will remember,
denounced political parties,
said that participation in
political parties was complicity
with slavery.
Garrison first read from
scripture--Old Testament,
Deuteronomy.
Then he proceeded to,
in three segments,
to burn documents.
He first held up in his hand
what he said was a copy of The
Fugitive Slave Act,
which he burned in his hand
with a lighted match,
threw the ashes on the floor,
stomped on the ashes,
and the crowd shouted "Amen."
Then he held in his hands the
documents for the rendition--he
said it was a copy of the
document for the rendition of
Anthony Burns,
returning Burns as a fugitive
slave to Virginia.
He burned that,
threw the ashes on the floor,
stomped on them,
and the crowd shouted "Amen."
Then he pulled out a copy of
the United States Constitution,
which he announced--as he had
announced many times over in his
newspaper,
The Liberator--he called
it a, quote, "covenant with
death, an agreement with Hell,
so perish all compromisers with
tyranny."
He burned it famously,
or infamously,
stomped on the ashes all over
the stage, and the crowd shouted
"Amen."
The Kansas-Nebraska Act had
fuelled a political fervor that
now could never be bottled up
again, it could never be put
back on its shelf.
Why?
Why was that Kansas-Nebraska
Act so troublesome?
Let me pick that up where I
left you off the other day.
Now remember,
the Kansas-Nebraska Act had two
simple resolutions,
although it came about through
a heightening process.
The first was that it
explicitly repealed the
36º30' parallel,
or Missouri Compromise line,
what Northerners--anti-slavery
abolitionist or even,
in some cases,
hardly-aware-of-slavery
Northerners--had always referred
as the,
quote, "sacred pledge."
That sacred pledge was now
thirty-four years old.
Everybody in the United States
Congress had grown up with it.
It was a template,
it was an assumption;
not unlike you could name
certain great resolutions or
assumptions that became almost
standard parts of American
political culture,
perhaps in your lifetime,
certainly in my lifetime.
Certain aspects of the New
Deal, we thought,
were basic American political
assumptions--like Social
Security, but recently that one
got challenged.
You could think of others.
The right to collective
bargaining out of the Wagner Act
in the 1930s.
You can think of others.
Some would say Roe v
Wade, some would say
affirmative action,
some would say other aspects of
our political culture born of
the 1960s.
Some would say the '64 Civil
Rights Act, et cetera.
The Missouri Compromise Line,
as people imagined this slavery
question in the West,
had been seen by Northerners
as, quote, "a sacred pledge."
That was now repealed
explicitly in this very
sectionalized,
divided vote in the
Kansas-Nebraska Act to set up
the Kansas-Nebraska Territories.
The second part,
was, of course,
a declaration that any state
produced, created from Kansas
and Nebraska would be created on
a principle of popular
sovereignty.
There would be a popular
referendum at some stage in the
territorial process,
to be worked out later.
It passed the U.S.
Senate thirty-seven to
fourteen.
That's in great part because
the Kansas-Nebraska Act became
an absolute test of Democratic
Party loyalty,
which Stephen Douglas demanded.
He didn't get all Democrats to
support it but he got most of
them.
And the Whig Party,
by 1864, in what was still a
fledgling two-party system,
now greatly challenged by a
third party called the American
Party, or known more
euphemistically as the
Know-Nothing party,
or known more directly as the
Nativist Party--more on that in
a moment--is really challenging
that two-party system.
But it was that vote in the
House that I showed you on a
graphic the other day that tells
you the story.
It passed the House of
Representatives 113 to 110,
in a highly sectionalized vote.
Ninety percent of all
Southerners, on Kansas-Nebraska,
voted for it;
sixty four percent of all
Northerners, people from Free
states, voted against it.
The second American party
system, born out of the struggle
over Jacksonian--so-called
Jacksonian democracy--from the
1820s into the '30s,
into the '40s,
into the early '50s,
was now disintegrating,
faster than most people even
really realized.
The effects of this were
quickly this:
the Kansas-Nebraska Act now
threw open the vast expanse of
what was left of the Louisiana
Purchase to the possible
expansion of slavery.
Secondly, it will destroy the
Whig Party forever,
and open a huge vacuum in
American political culture for
some kind of new coalition,
some kind of new persuasion
that would fill it,
about this great question of
its time--the expansion of
slavery.
And then more directly,
third, it brought overnight the
birth of the Republican
Party--the original Republican
Party,
I hasten to add--a party formed
literally overnight in reaction
to the Kansas-Nebraska Act.
It was often first called the
Anti-Kansas Party.
There are three or four towns
all over the Midwest in the
United States--Ripon,
Wisconsin;
Jackson, Michigan,
and others--that all claim to
be the site of the birth of the
Republican Party.
And they all have their little
monuments or their plaques in
town squares and parks to say
they were the place where the
first Republican Party meeting
was held.
But the Republican Party was
really born amidst hundreds of
meetings across the North,
to discuss the Kansas-Nebraska
Act, to react to it,
to figure out some way to
politically resist it.
That "hell of a storm:
that Stephen Douglas had
predicted, is exactly what
happened,
but he didn't have any clue the
direction or the ferocity of the
political storm that this would
cause.
To so many Northerners now,
who believed--for whom the
American dream was mobility in
the West,
availability of cheap if not
free land in the West,
the possibility of the small
farmer,
the small mechanic,
moving west and getting land in
a society without slaves--now
seemed to be completely thrown
up in the air,
if not denied.
I don't know what to really
compare it to today,
that might shock people.
Something you assumed was just
going to be there and tomorrow
it's not--it's just gone--and
you basically defined the future
of your children on it.
Lots of people now wondered
what happened to the Compromise
of 1850.
Well that was essentially a
dead letter.
And what was born in that
Republican Party,
what was born in those meetings
that formed the Republican Party
in the summer of 1854 was a
theory,
an idea they called "the slave
power conspiracy."
It actually wasn't born there,
that's an old idea,
the idea of a slave power.
But the idea of a slave power,
this notion of some kind of
conspiracy, a cadre,
an oligarchy,
a small number of great
planters in the Deep South that
nevertheless had tremendously
disproportionate power over
their own states,
over their own region,
and then in the Congress and in
the Supreme Count and in the
Presidency,
was an old idea.
I've found it as early as the
1820s in an old,
old article I once wrote where
people were actually already
using the term,
"the slave power."
But it really crystallized in
the 1850s.
This is a poster,
one of hundreds,
thousands of posters from 1854
calling for a meeting.
It doesn't even use the term
Republican Party anywhere,
just calling people
together--it's in Chester,
Pennsylvania I think--just
calling people together to
discuss the Kansas-Nebraska Act,
to discuss what's really
happened here,
and to discuss the slave power.
Classic nineteenth century
broadside with eight things
going on at once in front of
your eyes,
but the boldest print is
reserved for the slave power:
fear, conspiracy,
come together,
watch out, get ready.
The fear now,
you see--think closely about
this--to Northerners was,
"now wait a second,
if what the Kansas-Nebraska Act
is saying is that the
Louisiana--all the rest of the
Louisiana Purchase is now open
to the possible expansion of
slavery--it's got to be rooted
in a constitutional theory that
probably is supporting that
Fifth Amendment which is the
right to life,
liberty, and property,
and the transport of that
property anywhere you want.
So what's to stop someday,
somehow, slave holders from
coming into Illinois,
Ohio, New York,
Boston?"
It might seem a bit
far-fetched, but editorials
started appearing all over the
North,
like this one from The New
York Post that predicted,
quote, "Gangs of men and women,
chained together may yet be
seen now marching up or down
Broadway, or trembling in
Battery Park."
What was born in that summer,
and especially that fall,
was the most rapid third-party
political coalition movement in
all of American history;
and if you want a prototype for
any possibility of that kind,
any other time in our political
history, this is it.
The Republican Party,
brand new--not six months
old--will elect 100 people to
the House of Representatives in
the fall elections of 1854,
and they will begin to draw
together a remarkable coalition.
They're going to draw first a
whole lot of old Whigs,
Northern Whigs in particular,
who don't have any home
anymore.
This is the old Whig Party of
Henry Clay, but it's also the
old Whig Party that had a
reformist element to it.
This was the old John Quincy
Adams wing of the Whig Party.
And there were some Whigs who
had become genuine
abolitionists,
in many states,
and they now were looking for a
real political home in which to
plant their flag--of not just
free soil,
but a moral case against
slavery.
You got the old Free Soilers.
The Free Soil Party had existed
in 1848 and in the 1852
elections--remember,
I told you they elected,
what was it,
four people to the House of
Representatives.
But more importantly,
that Republican Party now had
tremendous--we're calling it now
"crossover,"
aren't we--tremendous crossover
appeal to Northern Democrats,
lifelong Northern Democrats who
will now break with Stephen
Douglas,
break with popular sovereignty,
break with their own political
lives, and join a new free-soil
anti-slavery party.
David Wilmot,
the author of the Wilmot
Proviso, you'll remember from a
week ago,
that Pennsylvania Democrat who
launched this idea during the
debates on the Mexican War that
said in any state formed from a
territory gained from the
Mexican War slavery shall never
exist,
the basic free soil position.
In 1854, David Wilmot became a
Republican.
This new political coalition,
fledging as it was--a lot of
strange bedfellows here,
guys who had just fought like
hell with each other for years
in the Congress were now kind of
forming the same party.
They're forming it around a few
key ideas.
One is this notion,
this idea of a slave power that
has to be resisted now.
As a political force it has to
be resisted, as an expansionist
migration force it has to be
resisted, as a labor system it
has to be resisted.
And secondly,
they are rooting their
political future and ideology in
what they're calling,
quite explicitly now--and
they've rehearsed this,
many of them for some years--an
anti-slavery interpretation of
the Constitution.
They're going to now really
rehearse publicly the idea that
"yes, slavery may be protected
constitutionally where it
already exists,
because slaves are legally
property.
Okay, we've heard that for
decades," they're going to say.
But the Federal Government has
jurisdiction over territories,
it has jurisdiction over the
District of Columbia,
and the slogan that flows from
this idea of an anti-slavery
interpretation of the
Constitution is "make freedom
national,
slavery sectional."
That slavery shall forever be,
they say, a regional,
sectional, local institution,
not a national institution,
which was an implicit way of
saying the West shall be kept
free for free labor at all cost.
And then thirdly,
the Republican party is
rooted--and this is why it could
become a coalition--it's rooted
in this cluster of ideas we've
come to call here--and Bruce
Levine's book is terrific on
this--a free labor ideology.
A fear of concentrated power,
the defense of the individual,
the small man.
It was a fanfare for the common
man, the small farmer or the
small clerk, the small--small in
the sense of--he has nothing,
he may own nothing,
but he wants to own something.
It's the immigrant with nothing
who wants to own a farm,
and he must have,
at least in this America of its
boundless West,
he must have physical mobility,
geographical mobility.
And historians have come to
define all of this,
of course, under this cluster
of notions we call
Republicanism,
the belief that the United
States was, if not a democracy,
at least a Republic,
where the people rule,
where consent of a majority
really counts.
And if that majority is
increasingly becoming small
farmers and clerks and
mechanics,
and a lot of them immigrants,
then oligarchies ought to be
put on the run,
whether those oligarchies are
bankers or those oligarchies are
made up of slaveholders.
This was in its birth,
and for the next six years,
one of the most potent
political coalition ideologies
this country has ever seen.
Now, what happens next?
What happens to this new
coalition?
And why are they going to be so
threatening to the South?
This in some ways is going to
become the planter elite,
Southern slaveholding class's
greatest fear,
a genuine Yankee,
anti-slavery Northern political
party.
After all, the North now has
close to, pushing,
a two to one advantage in
population;
that is if we simply define
that by Free states,
Slave states.
Now, maybe you've seen this
picture before.
It's a lithograph of the famous
beating of Charles Sumner in the
spring of 1856,
on the floor of the U.S.
Senate, by Preston Brooks.
Now, how do we get to a scene
in the U.S.
Senate of a Southern
Congressman beating the hell out
of a Massachusetts Senator,
beating him literally
unconscious, bloodying him on
the floor of the Senate,
while his fellow senators look
down, and some of them in glee?
There were ninety-one Northern
Democrats in the House of
Representatives when they voted
on the Kansas-Nebraska Act.
After the fall elections of
1854 there were only twenty-five
left.
This is a political sea change
happening and no one quite knows
where it's going yet.
And in that same year of 1854,
this Nativist Party--they
called themselves the American
Party--a party that stood
essentially for trying to stop
Catholic--mainly
Catholic--immigration into the
United States.
This was the moment of
course--I mean look around
today, we've got a huge debate
going on about immigration and I
won't go into that--but you can
see how it's clustering in parts
of our political
culture--heighten that six times
over to the early 1850s.
The huge Irish migrations to
the United States had just
happened between the mid-1840s,
especially the late-1840s,
and about 1852 to '54.
This is the moment,
the historical moment,
of the terrible,
infamous potato famine in
Ireland.
The Nativist Party was
anti-Catholic,
anti-immigrant.
They believed that Catholicism
would undermine American
Protestant values and the
Protestant work ethic.
They believed that a United
States of America ought to be a
white, Anglo-Saxon,
Protestant nation,
as it was in its founding.
They believed in a conspiracy
of Popery;
crazy as that may seem to some
of us today.
They believed that Catholics
owed and demonstrated a higher
loyalty to the Pope in Rome than
they ever would in the United
States,
to the United States
Government, and therefore
Catholics could not be true
Republicans.
I know, give me a break,
but it is what this party was
rooted in.
And man did they succeed.
They won huge electoral
victories in the fall of 1854,
particularly because there's
this new vacuum now,
the Whig Party's dead.
By 1856, in the Presidential
election of '56,
the Nativist American Party
candidate will win over 800,000
votes for the presidency--more
on that in a second.
The American Party won forty
seats in the U.S.
Congress in 1854.
They dominated a few northern
state legislatures.
They won the governorship of
Massachusetts and a majority of
its legislature.
It shocked people.
It shocked some Northern
Democrats who weren't
comfortable with this nativism,
the virulence of this nativism,
to become Republicans instead.
Now out west,
of course, what's going to
happen to Kansas and Nebraska?
Kansas now became the object of
tremendous migration.
It was nothing but a series of
frontier settlements in 1855,
but large numbers of people
began to go there.
These were the so-called
squatters, squatter farmers.
But immediately,
it became a contest between how
many Yankees and Northerners
would actually get there and try
to make the place free soil,
and how many Southerners would
actually get there,
with slaves,
and try to produce a
pro-slavery constitution.
Kansas became the great testing
ground of popular sovereignty.
Immigrant aid societies
emerged, especially in New
England.
One famous one that had a lot
of financial backing behind it,
called the New England Emigrant
Aid Society,
they recruited settlers,
they raised money,
they paid people's way out to
Kansas,
in some cases.
Kansas now became a kind of
symbol and reality.
Out on its border,
of course--its eastern border
was the state of Missouri,
which was a Slave state,
and Missourians began to flock
across the border into Kansas,
taking land.
By March of 1855,
only one year,
less than a year,
11 months after the passage of
the Kansas-Nebraska Act,
they held their first election
for a territorial legislature in
the Territory of Kansas.
An estimated 5,000 so-called
border ruffians--or that meant
Missourians--flocked over into
Kansas for a day or two to vote.
The census--they took a rapid
census in the early spring of
1855 in Kansas--recorded 2,905
eligible voters in all of
Kansas.
In that territorial legislation
election, 6,307 people voted;
way more than half of the
people registered to vote voted.
Something was wrong.
They elected a pro-slavery
legislature, adopted a
pro-slavery constitution
overnight.
And Free Soilers cried foul,
formed their own attempt at a
government that summer.
And by January of 1856,
the beginning of the next year,
in a sense, in essence,
there were two fledgling
territorial governments in
Kansas, one free soil,
one pro-slavery.
And it was then--that spring of
1856--that what we call Bleeding
Kansas, this border frontier,
civil war, this village against
village, river ravine against
river ravine,
broke out.
Before it played out over about
a year and a half about 250
people would be killed--many of
them in nighttime raids and
vigilante violence--and millions
in treasure.
I will come back to John Brown
later, next week in fact.
Our friend John Brown from
upstate New York--or somebody's
friend, he wasn't easy to be
friends with--had already sent
out some of his sons--more on
that later--and John Brown
arrived himself in the winter of
1856.
John Brown, a genuine,
radical, deeply religious Old
Testament abolitionist who went
to Kansas,
make no mistake,
to make Kansas free and to kill
slaveholders if necessary,
in what he believed was a
justifiable war.
That spring,
John Brown with his band of men
was traveling along the road
when he got news of the beating
of Charles Sumner in the Senate.
What happened in the Senate is
that Charles Sumner,
the radical abolitionist
Senator from Massachusetts,
one of only a tiny
handful--actually one of only
two or three,
three or four--real card
carrying abolitionists,
if we want to call them that,
who had seats in the U.S.
Senate.
Sumner, deeply well-educated,
classically educated,
Harvard man,
began his political life as a
so-called Conscience Whig in
Massachusetts.
He got elected to the U.S.
Senate in the fervor over the
Mexican War and in the fervor
over the expansion of slavery.
In his first few years in the
Senate, from 1849,
'50, '51, '52,
they had a virtual gag on him.
Any time Sumner tried to get
the floor--this went on for
about four years--there were all
kinds of parliamentary maneuvers
that the opposition could use to
prevent him from speaking.
They didn't want abolitionist
rhetoric in the halls of the
U.S.
Senate.
But with time he got a
position, that is,
a place where he could speak,
in the Senate's calendar.
And he did, he delivered a
speech early that spring called
"The Crime Against Kansas."
He delivered it in March 1856.
It took him about six hours.
It was later published in a
pamphlet form.
It's about 35,40 pages.
It was the classic free soil
argument of what was now the
Republican Party,
and Sumner was by now,
of course, a Republican.
He made all the arguments about
a slave power conspiracy and an
anti-slavery interpretation of
the Constitution.
He argued deeply into the
cluster of ideas we call free
labor ideology.
But then he laced the speech,
over and over,
with personal attacks on
Southerners, personal attacks on
Southern slave holders.
He singled out especially
Senator Andrew Butler of South
Carolina, and he used Butler's
alleged fathering of children by
a slave woman as representative
of what Sumner said was a common
practice across the south.
You could not imagine laying a
bigger taboo on your fellow
Southern senators than this one.
He described Butler as,
"a Don Quixote who had taken
the harlot slavery as his
mistress."
And then he went on and on with
that.
He was jeered.
Southerners started shouting at
him and Sumner just enjoyed it
and went on;
many of them walked out.
But he had already had copies
of the speech printed.
He had copies of the speech on
the street within a few days.
In the audience that day,
sitting up in the balcony,
was a member of the U.S.
House of Representatives named
Preston Brooks who was the
nephew of Senator Butler.
About a week after this event,
it may have been two weeks,
Butler decided that he was
going to have honor,
he was going to exercise an act
of honor and revenge deeply
rooted in what he believed was
the Old South sense of honor.
He had thought about
challenging Sumner to a duel,
but duels by this point in time
were highly illegal,
even though people did get
challenged--read my colleague
Joanne Freeman on this.
They're still challenging each
other to duels all the time in
the 1850s;
well, a lot of times.
But he decided against
challenging Sumner to a duel.
Instead, he thought he would
take a sort of Plan B--he would
meet Sumner at his desk with a
cane and try to kill him.
And he did.
Brooks took a cane to
Sumner--Sumner was sitting at
his desk, literally signing
copies of "The Crime Against
Kansas" speech to be sent out.
And he got trapped in the desk,
we're told;
he couldn't get out of it and
Brooks just kept banging on his
head, over and over,
just bloodied him into
unconsciousness,
and Sumner fell on the floor.
And there are all kinds of
stories--and in fact this
lithograph tries to capture it,
although I'm not sure you can
see it very well--there are all
kinds of stories about Senators,
especially Southerners,
gathering around and saying,
"Hold me back,
hold me back,"
as they smiled and watched
Sumner bleed on the floor.
And finally somebody grabbed
Brook's cane and said,
"You know, that's probably
enough."
[Laughter]
I mean, by any definition this
was an assault with a deadly
weapon, this was an assault and
battery, it was attempted
murder.
Preston Brooks went back to the
House of Representatives,
tendered his resignation and
said he would go back home to
South Carolina and submit
himself to the people of his
district.
And he did.
And they overwhelmingly
re-elected him.
He also received more than one
hundred commemorative canes in
the mail, some of which you can
see today at the Caroliniana
Library in Columbia,
South Carolina.
This became,
of course, a cause
célèbre,
a brutal example now of the way
in which compromise was being
ruined,
middle realm for moderation,
was perhaps being destroyed.
Violence had broken out all
over Kansas;
violence had now broken out in
the U.S.
Senate.
It led many people to a fearful
set of expressions;
there are literally hundreds of
these in the press.
This is one from William Cullen
Bryant who wrote in The New
York Evening Post,
after the news broke of the
beating of Sumner;
I quote him:
"A violence reigns in the
streets of Washington.
Violence has now found its way
into the Senate Chamber.
Violence lies in wait all over
the navigable rivers and all the
railways of Missouri to obstruct
those who pass from the Free
states into Kansas.
Violence overhangs the
frontiers of that territory like
a storm cloud charged with hail
and lightening.
Violence has carried election
after election in that
territory.
In short, violence is the order
of the day.
The North is to be pushed to
the wall by it,
and this plot will succeed if
the people of the Free states
are as apathetic as the
slaveholders are insolent."
It was news of the beating of
Sumner on the floor of the
Senate that apparently made John
Brown snap and within 48 hours
he led what's called the
Pottawattamie Creek Massacre
where he murdered five
pro-slavery advocates,
in cold blood,
with broad swords,
in the dark of the night.
We will return to John Brown's
exploits next week.
Now, that year was though a
presidential election year,
and the problem is still just
laying there out on the
landscape.
What is to happen with
Kansas-Nebraska?
What's to be done with Bleeding
Kansas?
What's to be done with--?
Now in that election of
1856--this is terribly important
just to note for a moment--the
Republican Party will mount its
first effort at the presidency.
And it all but won.
This had never happened in
American history till then,
it's never happened since,
a new third party had come so
close to winning.
The platform of the Republican
Party in 1856 was,
if anything,
slightly more radical than it
had been two years earlier in
those congressional elections of
1854.
They took a staunch stand about
slavery expansion.
They took a staunch stand on
keeping Kansas free.
They announced,
directly, that they would,
quote, "destroy slavery
wherever Federal jurisdiction
reigned."
For President they ran John C.
Fremont, a young,
dashing, romantic,
heroic type.
He had been one of the great
surveyors and explorers of the
West.
He was already known by the
nickname "the Pathfinder," and
he was the first Senator from
the state of California.
He's also the son-in-law of
Thomas Hart Benton,
a very powerful--now
Republican--from Missouri.
He was well married,
well connected and
good-looking.
They centered their
campaign--they borrowed Sumner's
own language--and they centered
their campaign on what the
Republican Party itself now
called "the crime against
Kansas."
They were also for tariffs,
for the transcontinental
railroad across the West and so
on.
The American Party,
known as the Know-Nothings,
by the way, because in their
origins--if you didn't know this
about the Know-Nothings-- in
their origins the American
Nativist Party tried to maintain
a secrecy--they were kind of a
secret society at first-- and
when asked who they were and how
they met and what they were for,
the original members would
always say they knew nothing.
So anytime you hear that term,
Know-nNthingism,
in American politics,
if somebody throws--if Chris
Matthews throws that term off at
you,
showing of his political
history knowledge--it usually
means nativism,
or it means some kind of third
party phenomenon.
The Know-Nothings nominated
that year Millard Fillmore,
former president;
he'd been the President during
the Compromise of 1850.
It was a very strange choice.
And the Know-Nothings were now
in some trouble because of this
powerful new Republican
coalition which is managing now
to draw some of the Nativists
into them,
because it turns out some
Nativists were actually more
afraid of the slaveholding
oligarchy than they were of this
Catholic conspiracy.
If they had to choose
conspiracies they were a little
more frightened of slaveholders
than Popes.
The Democrats went safe,
they chose a largely
incompetent James Buchanan to
run for President.
He was from Pennsylvania--kind
of lower north.
He was known to have very
strong ties to the South and to
be what Republicans are already
calling a doughface,
which meant a Northerner with
Southern sympathies.
And he had been the United
States Ambassador to Britain
during the Kansas-Nebraska
crisis, so he had never voted on
it;
he had no position to defend.
It was a highly sectionalized
election.
Buchanan carried every Slave
state except Maryland,
and then he carried New Jersey,
Pennsylvania,
Indiana, Illinois and
California.
The Democratic Party was still
a national party.
Fremont, the Republican,
carried the rest of the Free
states and New England
decisively.
Fremont and Fillmore
together--and Fillmore,
the Nativist candidate,
got 850,000 votes;
Buchanan about 1.8 million;
Fremont about 1.5,1.6
million--no, 1.3 million.
If the Nativist Party had not
been in this election and if
most of the Nativists had gone
to Fremont,
the Republican,
or even two-thirds of them,
Fremont would've won the
presidency.
This anti-slavery northern
coalition of free soil advocates
came very close.
They would even call it,
in its wake,
a victory within defeat,
for such a brand new political
party.
Now, out in Kansas they're
still trying to hold elections;
one corrupt,
fraudulent election after
another.
Buchanan took office in the
spring of '57.
He appointed a new governor for
the Territory of Kansas named
Robert J.
Walker whose job it was going
to--he was a solid Pennsylvania
Democrat but nevertheless said,
"I will go out and there and
enforce popular sovereignty.
We're going to have a true,
free ballot in Kansas.
Popular sovereignty is still
going to work."
The trouble was,
popular sovereignty was now
dead in the water.
It was tainted, at best.
In the election of delegates to
yet another attempt at a state
constitutional writing
convention in Kansas in the fall
of 1857,
the Free Soilers boycotted the
election.
So at Lecompton,
Kansas--and hence the term the
Lecompton Constitution--a
pro-slavery constitutional
convention met,
with the Free Soilers all
boycotting, and they drafted--no
mistake--a pro-slavery
constitution.
It protected slavery and the
right to slave ownership
eternally, forever,
in the state of Kansas.
It excluded from residence in
the state of Kansas any free
negroes, and it said that it
could not be amended,
in any way, for seven years.
This process had taken drastic
liberties with the idea of
popular sovereignty,
which as you'll remember was
the idea you're supposed to have
a popular referendum and just
let the vote determine whether
slavery shall exist.
This Governor Walker lost
control of the territory,
violence continued--terrible
violence.
And Walker came back to
Washington, urged his own
president, who had appointed
him, to not support this
Lecompton Constitution.
He said it's just--it's not
right, it's just too fraudulent.
It was boycotted by half of the
people, probably more than half
the people, and Buchanan made a
fateful decision.
He said, "Nope.
They've had their popular
sovereignty, they've had their
constitutional writing
convention.
If the Free Soilers chose not
to participate that's the way it
goes."
And Buchanan took the Lecompton
Constitution to Congress and
asked for its approval,
of Kansas as a Slave state.
Buchanan took huge political
risks here and didn't--for all
practical purposes--apparently
know what he was doing.
And here we begin to see now
the breakup, the tearing apart,
now of even the Democratic
Party,
because none other than Stephen
Douglas, father of popular
sovereignty, author of the
Kansas-Nebraska Act,
the man who had pushed that act
through, went to Buchanan and
said, "No sir,
you cannot support the
Lecompton Constitution,
it's a fraudulent constitution.
The majority of the people in
that territory are probably free
soil.
You can't do this."
He broke with his own
President, and it would be
disastrous for the Democratic
Party.
The Lecompton Constitution was
not accepted by the Congress.
Now, the Dred Scott decision,
which came down that same
spring of 1857 in the immediate
aftermath of Buchanan's
election--there's old Dred,
not a great picture of him,
but it's the only photograph we
have of Dred Scott--the Dred
Scott decision also came down in
the midst of a major American
depression.
The so-called Panic of 1857
broke out that very spring.
The same time as Buchanan is
being inaugurated,
the Lecompton Constitution is
being forged out in Kansas,
the Dred Scott decision is
going to be announced,
the country is falling into a
horrible economic panic.
There are many causes of it.
I wish I had the time.
Actually, I'm going to save the
Panic of 1857 because it sets up
Lincoln and Douglas in '58,
'59 for me later.
But I want to leave you--I've
got three minutes I think,
two minutes,
two, three--with this fateful
Supreme Court Case;
many people like to say the
worst Supreme Court decision in
all of American history,
but I suspect you can get up a
debate over that.
I think we've had a couple of
others;
I won't name them.
Who was Dred Scott?
This man, who was an old man by
the time the Supreme Court ruled
on him and put his name forever
into American history as a
symbol,
was born a slave in 1795 in
Virginia.
He had moved to Missouri in the
1820s with his master,
a man--his original master's
name was Peter Blow.
He was then later owned by a
physician, a doctor named John
Emerson.
Emerson was an Army surgeon,
and Emerson traveled from
Missouri all over the upper
Midwest and into what then was
the Great Plains as an Army
surgeon working at Army camps
and bases.
Dred Scott went with him as his
personal servant.
They traveled to Illinois and
Minnesota.
Dred Scott lived with his
master from 1834 to 1838,
four years, with Dr.
Emerson, on various kinds of
military bases,
especially in Minnesota,
a free territory.
At one point,
Dred Scott tried to buy his own
freedom in Minnesota and wasn't
allowed to do it.
He married a free black woman
named Harriet while he was in
Minnesota.
Four years residence on free
soil, an attempt to buy his own
freedom, marries a free black
woman.
Emerson brought him back to
Missouri in 1838 and through an
intricate series of events for
the next five to six years-- not
the least of which was Missouri
is a very divided place,
especially St.
Louis--a group of anti-slavery
folk gathered around Dred Scott
and tried to help him sue for
his freedom.
In 1846, they moved his case
through local courts,
and the first decision--was at
a local court--because of his
residence and free soil for four
years,
gave Dred Scott his freedom.
That court decided the case in
1850.
It was then appealed by the
State of Missouri,
which was really worried about
this case,
to the Missouri Supreme Court,
and the Missouri Supreme Court,
by a decision of two to one,
ruled no, no, no.
On appeal, Dred Scott's freedom
would be denied--that he did not
have the right to his freedom
because of residence on free
soil.
Then, again with the help of an
anti-slavery group,
and even his own owner,
believe it or not,
they pushed this appeal to the
U.S.
Supreme Court.
Dr.
Emerson was gone,
Dred was now owned by a man
named John Sanford,
and hence the case is called
Sanford versus Scott.
Scott's case came before the
U.S.
Supreme Court as early as 1854
and got on the docket.
It would not be decided for
2½ years.
Most people didn't even know
this was happening.
I'll leave you here.
Only three days after James
Buchanan was inaugurated
President, having just only
narrowly defeated this new
Republican coalition,
news broke in Washington of
something called the Dred Scott
decision, and it would electrify
the political culture of the
country.
It will fuel this Republican
Party anti-slavery coalition as
much as--in some places--as much
as the Kansas Nebraska act ever
had,
and it will inspire Abraham
Lincoln to run for the senate.
That's it for now.